[Musica]
j am bucks e ragazzi buongiorno
benvenuti a questo nuovo episodio
unboxing dj oggi siamo qua con un nuovo
pacco questa frase è la cosa che ha
coronato tutta la mia vita
paco e finalmente se ci spiegate perché
a queste scritte strani questo oggi
faremo una valutazione valutazione prima
di aprirlo cosa che non ho mai fatto
cioè facciamo tutti a me le forbici
grazie ragazzi andiamo ad abbozzare il
pacco di oggi io non so che non è vero
non mi fai da te devi stare cosa ti
aspetti ma con un tavolo da campeggio a
casa dei tuoi figli né un pic nic unic
in giardino in giardino si tanto la
temperatura c'è ok perfetto loro andiamo
buongiorno
ciao mamma ciao ciao ciao cani veramente
più bello quindi ragazzi l'ospite di
oggi e a sorpresa anche per me e mio
papà che non compariva sul mio canale da
un po 6 per prima mi ha mai aperto
queste sono le cose le cose ecco mi sa
che avete fatto apposta per mio padre
questo palco immagino ben si vede
partiamo dal primo oggetto no vabbè la
sua intera di r2 d2 facevano c1 mitigata
bellissimo ma veramente tappo a no ho
capito e cosa che ti fa la schiuma ha
cambiato aprile 29th coso qua e poi fa
così schiuma guido non fa schiuma si
questo come funziona la strega non
sapete come si vive metti il latte che
così riesce la schiuma ruvido è vero
sentite io di queste cose spaziali non
lo so next
non è vero è la tazza di ritorno al
futuro quella del praticamente tu cosa
fai
ho già capito se la riempì di acqua
calda di cose calde quali sbaglio una
lavata si illuminano le date che vedo
che figata
io da collezionista non averne anche
portare alla scapola però matteo da
iniziamo aspetta ma che sfiga non vuoi
provare a metterci dentro qualcosa
vedere cosa dopo lo mettiamo dopo le
prossime lo scelgo io è un classicone
questo mensa che trovo già anche fatto
provare alle camere di un secondo sono
le caramelle di harry potter che hanno
ognuna ha un gusto particolare nel senso
che gusto verme terra cannella ciliegia
passiamo al pro snai librino mi sembra
shampoo se era quel sapone quindi la
buona ma che schifo
devo finire devo mangiare la tuta sì
perché non puoi più sputarla quindi
mangiato un gran novak è questa la cosa
incredibile questa non lo lasci ti prego
l'unico
la cosa mi devi lasciare questo qua è
semplicemente le sentiamo adescato
l'harley questo è semplicemente un sushi
in star trek oriente loro prendono la
navicella disco si chiama sana vice
listino guardare chi interpreta questa
l'enterprise in questa parte
dell'enterprise ci sta il capitano che
fa metti la salsa di toglie la metti qua
che questi li le bacchette e qua ci
metti il sushi e tu prenditi uscire le
bacchette
cioè io non so chi chi ha partorito
quest'idea però è veramente fantastica e
peraltro sotto istituì vulcaniano non si
capisce dove comunque star trek susciti
st 3
non ti piace il sushi me lo tengo io
next da cosa partire quindi a noi utente
su questo che il più grosso di due
allora che non averlo capito è
semplicemente un no una in italiano una
panca e chi era ma non a voi preparate
la pasta quella proprio buona l'uovo
mettete le uova quelle rigorosamente
vulcania ne apriamo le mettiamo
qua facciamo tutta la pasta per chiudi
perché sta per esplodere tutto quindi
capri poi così tirate fuori la la
pastiera e che esce da pancake e
formativi ecco fornire per biscotti
allora tu metti o la sabbia oppure ci
metti biscotti e fai i personaggi di
star wars quindi ragazzi adesso vediamo
la scatola mettiamo un po tutte le cose
che abbiamo trovato io vi dico questo
forse mi piace un sacco per credo che
sia piaciuto di più a lui nel far fronte
la chiusura
se noi mettiamo c più ridicoli di contro
non siano già successo quindi ragazzi
spero che vi siano alto sono i grembiuli
cosa dobbiamo fare noi
nesic cuochi no che si cucina quindi
ragazzi facciamo i biscotti perché le
formine servono a questo
siccome io non so fare i biscotti mi
appoggio a antonino che li fa
facciamo i biscotti uovo io riprendo
perché io influenza 13 io li prendo te
mentre lo fai ti riguarda questa è una
tecnica che valeva parata militare
ma no ma cosa ha fatto il contrario ha
veramente la regione leader le uova
abbiamo fatto e adesso pari la farina
vai vai vai mettendo il bastone tanto un
po come facciamo una grotta farina a
sentimento fare votiamo corroborano
capace e fai 44 bocchetti nostro blog
no non così un po più grosso uovo farina
burro è detto lieto lievito quanto lieve
non so neanche come fattore di lievito
fatto mancano su quanto zucchero nel
tempo
vabbè 100 g di zucchero hanno però
momenti ne mette perché frullato ma no
allora ragazzi c'è un problema di fondo
e io non sono
non sono capace peggiorato la situazione
bene la pasta dei biscotti
effettivamente esistono le magie ragazzi
abbiamo fatto sto casino per fare
ovviamente le formine allora prendere un
po di farina e poi schiacciamo con la
formina l'impasto per la mifid ata
vengono dalla dashboard così ne vengono
2 basta così mamma
fantastico ecco perché sembra trovate
poi prendiamo tutta la forma la mettiamo
qua è è uno l'abbiamo fa incredibile
ragazzi sono incredibilmente sorpresi
mese ora bravo effetto più di forma
aspettiamo mezz'ora e vediamo come i
risultati biscotti tiri fuori tirai
fuori vedere dopo che sono passati 30
minuti signori signori a poliziotti sono
bruciati sim i complimenti chiosa è
aumentato afroamericano allora adesso
che abbiamo il nostro impasto pronto
mettiamo il piatto cosa è diventato
questo canale nel tempo e facciamo i
banchi allora bisogna questa questo
rumore su di te devi versare nella cosa
un po di questo impasto quanto ne
versiamo come solo innesto qua ci ho
messo io lo prendo
signori è chiuso se chiudo signori come
si fa però tirato fuori signori adesso
fare una cosa incredibile per tirarla
fuori
svetta aspettava una cosa incredibile
per dire una cosa faremo una cosa
incredibile che mai usato la prima volta
che usiamo i pancakes made in famiglia o
sony sono pronti io sono orgoglioso
della mia discendenza facciamo il caffè
apriamo r2 d2 e mettiamo detto il caffè
dentro mettiamo nel caffè trio fatto
bisognerebbe mettere credo l'acqua ca
l'acqua calda
ancora un po ancora un po hanno ancora
un po lancio del progetto adesso in
teoria questo ti amo senza fare rosa
inciso e spingerlo lentamente facendo
pressioni molti genitori versa al gun
città di caserta salga allestita le
scarpe satta che vediamo se funziona
vincitori di mano piano mi sento la roma
sentito male subito
lasciarlo lì si versa il caffè
all'americana dentro sul tavolo sul
tavolo sversiamo sul tavolo si versa il
caffè e il risultato è buono perché il
caffè versato adesso dovrebbe fare
comparire sulla tazza i numeri compaiono
le scritte bellissimo tranne l'ultima
perché ovviamente il caffè qua non ci è
arrivato però che le scritte sono
comparse così vediamo la differenza
della prima e dopo fratelli brucia no
perché non è peraltro perché non sai che
non è male se ci metti lo zucchero
secondo me ci penso perché va bene
quindi ragazzi il finale di questo video
si può concludere con i biscotti ha
inzuppato chewbecca erano unico venuto
ben maggiore gli altri caffè biscotti
pancake mi ha fatto un po di tutto non
so come sia riuscito come siamo riusciti
a fare sta roba non va beh per cortesia
grazie papà per possiamo chiudere video
prima di fare questa cosa va bene però
che vi sia piaciuto caso di seguito più
da quel momento mi piace ricordati non
imitate c per fare ste robe perché abbia
fatto un casino però tutto sommato siamo
ancora vivi ci vediamo un pò seguito un
box info di gela belle ragazze
[Musica]